[Music]
foreign I do not no I think it would be
a big overreach I don't think that we're
at the point where they need to step in
and help regulate it I think a little
bit of government involvement along with
people and like the private sector would
be nice I wouldn't necessarily say the
government itself but yes they should be
involved keep the government out of
regulating things
they regulate too many things already at
this point I can't see on what they
would base the regulations and I can't
see on what they would
remove the restrictions what they would
use to bring the restrictions into place
and then what they would use what
rationale they would use to remove them
so I think it could become a a mess that
they can't get out of I think it just
depends on the situation and
um you know it's what it can and can't
do I don't think that the government
should interfere with where technology
is headed where AI is headed until it
starts interfering with our privacy I do
think there should be laws and
regulation that AI is bound by whether
or not it's government oversight per se
like a committee I think that's going to
depend on how the technology advances
there has to be some sort of oversight I
don't know if the government is the most
efficient way to do it
um but there has to be some sort of
board maybe that would convene with
sort of
non-political or governmental officials
um so maybe a combination this
technology is going to affect all sorts
of different parts of our lives and
those parts are likely to have different
laws that are going to be impacted by AI
with AI I think we're at the very first
steps where until we know what it's
capable of the government can't regulate
an unknown entity so when you talk about
whether or not the government is playing
a role really we're looking at laws and
regulations and AI is going to be
something that's going to cover a lot of
different areas of law including
copyright trademark it could cover
Estate Planning and other things like
that so there's going to be laws that
are already going to be affected by AI
so for instance if you have photographs
of people and then you want to use AI to
create a real person or a real video you
could be have some copyright
infringement or some personal
Privacy Act problems with that
foreign